[Music]
James Corden is in London also this week
for The Late Late Show and he spoke to
Carly Steele about how tomorrow night's
broadcast has been affected by
saturday's terror attack on the London
Bridge after what happened here in
London this weekend we you know we're
gonna have to think about our show
Corden had to scrap his opener after
they filmed 80% of it we don't know what
we're gonna do maybe it's a good time to
be doing show like this to show the
world the unbelievable spirit and
determination and strength of this great
city it's a beautiful place to be James
gave et an exclusive tour of his London
set a transformed Church with an
impressive view Harry Styles is going to
perform out on this roof this week shows
are packed with stunts featuring British
and American celebs here's an exclusive
clip of tomorrow night's carpool karaoke
with Ed Sheeran filmed in LA and we're
stuck in traffic yeah I'm on my way
stuck in some traffic on these bad
freeways back in London court indeed
crosswalk the musical as Mary Poppins
it's so silly and to be doing it with
Sir Ben Casey and enormous cultural
treat for me Jennifer Hudson you're
doing drop the mic yes how scared are
you to take on the Jay hud it's gonna be
brutal but knocking the wind out of
those star sails Tom Cruise we caught it
Tom's cruise on the river James Corden
haha it was very stupid but we had him
in all sorts you didn't see what was
happening on the boat oh my god what
happens on the phone you have to wait
and see he came to me with the whole
thing when I'm with him I don't know
whether to like shake his hand or lick
his face I just I'm so in love with him
and at one point where he had his top
off technically we are both man but we
could not look more different than we do
right now
[Music]
you